10 richest youtubers of 2021.
dang am i on here yeah i should be i'm
on here i mean the title yeah let's go
yeah we got all of them all david
dobrik's on here oh that's sad too bad
it could have been a good video
well we'll see i mean it could still be
i just saw this title and i'm like
that's the dumbest i ever seen i
got to watch this
youtubers
okay yeah you ready for this i'm ready
wait what
what's my net worth google my net worth
how much am i worth can i be on this
video
cinnamon toast can
wife why does that pop up first you've
been looking at my wife
excuse me
two million
how much i paid in taxes this year
please i mean
yes excuse hey here you're five million
hey a little more rich there we go but
they just make up numbers they do
that's what i was like looking at like
they just kind of make up like well
between the numbers of two dollars cpm
and seven dollars cpm
they're worth this
well that's why i'm curious to see this
yeah what are they gonna say yeah that
dream of starting a youtube channel in
the hopes of becoming the next david oh
what a cringe shot what the is this
that is that david
is it i think i think it is they just
said that youtubers hope they become
become the next this guy isn't that so
cringe
yes
we started this because it's like oh fun
to play games and and i was like
people want to get rich yeah that's the
core
yeah
read this back in our
entire day we didn't even know youtubers
could even really make money no
gaming made no money back in the day
yeah it was all vloggers and you
couldn't even get partnered you had to
sign away
half of whatever you earned just to even
be able to make money to begin with
that's how it worked back in the day
yeah it was amazing and then you had to
watch all these like shane dawson and
ray william johnson being huge and
you're like oh cool good for that i'm
like wow they can do it anybody can do
it let me
it was more inspiring back in the day no
it's the same it's the same it's the
same
yeah
side while you're editing this video you
may want to try to make me seem nicer i
don't know i've been in a i'm in a bad
mood i can't get my freaking right here
ken is in pain it's okay really no
people in the world that i hate more
than youtubers that don't know anyway so
okay this this is great this is a pr i
pull up the perfect video for you ken
let's keep watching for mr beast and
it's pretty easy to understand why these
famous youtubers are rolling in money
but just how rich can our favorite
e-celebs get off their videos and ever
expanding sub counts the real numbers
are sure to shock you that's why we're
about oh i'm about to get shocked
and yeah probably so because it's a
success no one's ever accurate with it
ever seen and you won't believe how much
these youtubers are actually making
ready to take a look let's get it on mr
beast oh we're starting with the beast
mr beast hey yeah
we did we're going in well i am kind of
curious because like his old business
model is to put the money he makes back
into the the business right well that's
what i was going to say is mr beast's
channel still like a normal individual
person kind of youtube channel kind of
like like mine like i do like react to
stuff for yourself even like a gameplay
channel his seems more like a
model to like put the money back into it
and just to grow it as big as he can i
guess even what it says on his twitter
that that's his goal is just to make the
biggest channel he can by
putting all the money into it he's the
epitome of you got to spend money to
make money yeah i guess so
so i'm just wondering whatever whenever
he eventually catches you and passes you
which you will i'm sorry it's just gonna
happen
will you still be able to say that
you're
like no no no i'm gonna i'm gonna start
i'm not i'm gonna go beyond mr beast i'm
gonna spend all the money that i've
accumulated and then i'm going to take
on a debt
[Music]
for it yeah i'm going to put in more
because i got to keep going i got to get
those subs man
i'm just wondering if you'll still be
able to work the angle that you're like
fighting the fight against companies
like you always do you know like coco
melon and series
i'm not doing that i'm not doing that
anymore because youtube will shut down
my channel that's true
you're talking trash about other people
make us a lot of money how could you
why are you always the fall guy why do
you always gotta be the one that takes
the l i gotta go in for the kill more
you know i gotta stop caving for to
these fools
arguably being the inventor of the now
massively successful genre of videos
where a youtuber gives away your spin
all right we're watching the same
claps over and over again shows
that everything mr beast has one of the
most successful merch empires in youtube
history with a recent video of his
showing that he sold
67 000 limited edition shirt okay so
they're doing the math on this then how
much he made them from there oh okay
they got some insider information they
know the split he's getting okay okay
let's see at the lowest price that's
over two million dollars made in a day
and the hoodies cost double that amount
with all his insane spending like giving
away an 800 thousand dollar island or
giving away one million dollars cash
every time he throws a competition we
know he's pulling in some undeniably
monstrous dough still let's look at
numbers from nothing but his youtube
views because even that fraction of his
income is enough to blow your mind are
they just like blowing through numbers
here like was the number based off of
like you know cost and like
all the backend stuff or was it just
like at the lowest price in total it was
two million dollars off the sale oh
right they didn't they just set a number
and then they're like instead of
explaining anything else they go but you
know
we don't really know how much money he's
making but this video is about you know
people that make a lot of money but we
don't know
i don't know why i did 20 times six to
seven thousand
they sell them at 20 bucks right or
something like that how much did hoodies
go for these i guess like 40 bucks
let's say there's like a
profit of 70 percent maybe 30 goes to
production of the woody and yeah
they got the call it depends you know
depends on who you are what kind of deal
you get but i mean it
probably happens it seemed like they did
they did all them on their own though
yeah so they probably got bigger they
get more for sure
uh anyway i'll just i'll just i feel
like they're fast talking me about like
how much money is going on here because
i'm actually trying to understand it
yeah it's kind of annoying i got you
enough to blow your mind in an average
year the main mr beast channel makes 13
million 860 000 and honestly that's
still a pretty seems low
well yeah seems like he's a bit low i
don't know adsense maybe
no but mr beast probably gets pretty
decent ads on his videos yeah i just
figured he would get way better ads than
nine days yeah 13 860 000 and honestly
that's still a pretty conservative
estimate that's more than 160
every single minute talk about making
money from your dreams
but
well now we go to meet so we can see how
accurate it is
oh yeah are you are you gonna are you
gonna spill the beans are you gonna i
don't know if i want to but we'll see
okay
gamers in youtube felix
hey how's my hand that was in this video
yeah i gave you the i gave you the award
i had the sparkly gloves on yes
look at all the there's only girls here
i didn't even realize what the
wow
that was in sweden i remember on the
planet with the incredibly long-lasting
dynasty pewdiepie still it's it's been
like 10 years max like is that really
that long kind of makes me sad i'm like
i mean in youtube years that's
pretty much
you're goddamn immortal well that's the
thing i mean like bro being the only
person to ever gain more than 100
million subscribers is a very lucrative
spot to be in aside from his personal
brand in an ever changing high quality
merch lineup high quality all right
let's go do you ever do you ever cringe
when you see yourself in these videos
like it's weird it makes it easier
watching it with you because it's like
we're watching someone else almost but
yes i definitely would yeah
i'm i'm very i don't know i guess
not myself i can't watch myself
same same i don't know when i go back
and watch the videos i'm in with you
like right now i'm like i'm talking to
felix man i wish i would just shut up
sometimes oh no brad nah
you know you never do it don't let me
feel that baby come on man
thanks bro you're the one that you get
100 meters that man not me man oh yeah
now you're lying all right
all right anyway let's see what you're
doing usually pulling in between 6 and
10 million views numbers no
that's not right anymore
homes in both england and japan yeah
those are my houses right there
definitely
some random designer clothes designers
getting billions of views a year
generally well conservative estimates
place pewdiepie's annual address i can't
wait to see this point two million get
the out of here
more than mr beast almost no no
that's a million dollars less than mr
beast
bro no ads my adsense is so
realistically my answer is like less
than half probably yeah you think so
yeah
i wonder why that is because
my adsense you know
is very high for my channel yeah i did
swore i swore it and youtube put me in
the category of like you know they have
a system you know they have a surprise
they have to yeah yeah
because i mean it used to be the same
for me and then like for years i started
doing react stuff and being more family
friendly
and now it's like i'm like why did i
ever play games ever because jesus
christ this is great it would have been
better for me if i just had 50 million
subs and was family friendly
it would yeah i want to get all this
right that would make equal amount
of money
i'm not going into big detail i'm not
trying to flex your ears on your video
about like how much money i make but
currently like a channel of the same
size as mine or same viewership yeah uh
just from me talking to different people
that i'm like doing like
i'm i'm doing as well as like a channel
like triple massage oh really
yeah see it's crazy how that works yeah
yeah i hope it stays that way because i
gotta buy a freaking house in australia
we gotta start that gofundme
he claimed that the numbers were still
increase his net worth to 68 million
oh you've done this before
uh
hi and that's exactly
all coming back for more
david oh wow that's so interesting
usually it's the reddit that calls you
out for making the same thing
let's say i have babies in the history
of youtube slovakian-born david dobrik
has done incredibly well for himself at
the young age of without any more eating
how much do you think his net worth went
down after all that she
him i think i have james charles in this
video too oh boy oh boy multiple
channels each boasting tens of millions
of subscribers it isn't hard to
understand how david keeps surprising
his friends with teslas and
he's he does a little bit of that mr
beast thing where he gives
so many thoughts at the same time the
whole giving car thing makes it just
seems like
money now
right yeah well but do you ever see the
people driving the car like after they
win it no no yeah oh
with just the things that came out right
like all the the issues that came out
david i'm i'm kind of wondering if it's
just like just for the video like they
just ran this car i don't know for sure
but i'm just
that comes to mind when i when i see
this no i think he probably gave cars
away
yeah i mean i hope i hope his friends
are making money because that's gonna be
a lot of tax they have to pay on that
car jesus
all right
yeah they have to pay like what twenty
percent how much is it yeah it's pretty
high it's yeah yeah yeah it's based off
the valuation of
the tax office when the uni show up
the tax office that's dumb give me
my lambo i wanna see i gave uh you know
buff pro that makes videos with me i
gave him a car when i left because i
didn't make a video about it or anything
like i was just like hey you know i'm
going to australia i want to make sure
you're good you know
i can't take this car with me i want you
to have it
and he calls me up like
uh two weeks later being like hey i
actually can't pay for the taxes oh
you know so i took care of everything
uh
yeah it's a real thing and i wouldn't i
didn't even think about it because i
didn't i gave i just gave it to him i
was like oh yeah i didn't sell it you're
not going to pay taxes right no there's
a gift tax and now i know about what it
what if you sell it for an undervalued
price
it does it doesn't matter they still tax
it off the valuation of i'm trying to
commit tax fraud here that's just
that's the same thing and he did too
he's like well you know what if i
you know had it in writing but i sold it
to him for x amount of price but that
would be you know illegal
and yeah it's just based off what they
they google it at the at the office and
tell you
this what if you make it look cash
transaction
it does it does it doesn't matter
well how the does mr beast do it
then he's gonna bankrupt all these
kids
didn't he like talk about that at one
point to where like he had yeah and it
seemed like he had no idea what the
answer was
there's no way he doesn't know come on
at least at this now he must know
well it's like even if you give them
money to pay for the taxes or something
they get taxed for that money right it's
like
never oh my god what the i didn't
think of that well ten thousand dollars
is the limit of like gifting people
money yeah in america so if you gift
them more than that and they gotta pay
taxes right oh my
god it's hard to give stuff away man oh
man dude that's funny i get i
understand restriction on gifts because
obviously then you can just gift
people and avoid taxes youtubers
committing tax fraud top 10
bra moments what is happening 1000 model
x and the 240 000 ferrari for his own
enjoyment i mean you've got to have an
appropriate couple of luxury vehicles
when you're living it up on a 9.5
million dollar mansion in the heart of
los angeles but is that what it costs
9.5 i didn't know that
that's dumb everybody took a loan
i bet you i bet you did but bro like why
would he need a house that big he's one
dude get that flex money bro that's
youtube has changed los angeles but how
does david dobrik get it all done well
with an average of nearly four million
views on his channel per day it's
estimated that dobrick's pulling in
around 6.6 million but no because he
already said that he doesn't make money
off his uh adsense because he keeps
getting like copyrighted because he use
copyrighted music all the time yeah
dude youtube has changed so much from
back in the day more more boomer can
talk here okay have we talked about this
before like how back in the day it was
not cool to like talk about how much
money you made dude even doing a brand
deal was like well i hope i don't get
canceled selling out you know yeah i was
terrified the first brand delay bid yeah
yeah and now it's like oh i'm making so
much money it's like what people want to
see now it's it's weird it's flipped
yeah i'm glad
i think that makes sense
yeah now go buy a nice car and be like
heck yeah and i can make a video off of
it and help pay for that car
as long as you're jeff bezos you can
you can do that or the opposite of what
i said because he thanked her he thanked
his customers for going to space and
everyone's like shut up
[Laughter]
thank you guys for this house it
wouldn't be for you
i wouldn't have gotten this house mate
you can't say that you're you're in
australia you're from adsense alone of
course with status that high
sponsorships and merch sales make up a
much larger chunk of his true interest
his channel's revenue is probably just
going into a hefty retirement account
for when his tesla model x can drive
itself to a mansion on mars which i'm
sure david will happily be vlogging
about along the way uh what a cringey
sentence
i didn't age well no oh dude perfect
yeah literally a team of five friends
with a passion for combining sports and
physics dude perfect has gone on to
become one of the biggest
i'm actually curious and i hope they do
some breakdown because they have a bunch
of tv shows and yeah yeah they got
a lot of stuff going on yeah and they've
done huge brand news actually they've
taken some randalls that i said no to
and i know what kind of money going into
those i don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
and i'm like i don't know how to promote
this we don't play raid shadow legends
you know be like ninja
goofy looking character put in there
i mean i can't say every brandy i've
done is perfect but uh i try to pick
some of these dude perfect's audience
currently outnumbers that of the nba mlb
and nfl combined so with an audience the
size of several nations it's not hard to
imagine that their income flows from a
huge number of sources making it hard to
track as a whole but just taking a look
at some of the ways the dude perfect
team has expanded their business it's
clear to see that 53 million subs rakes
in some serious cash flow with their
average 8 million god isn't this video
so obnoxious
it is i can't focus on it i can't focus
on what he's saying
i do i do appreciate how they keep
focusing on like the subscriber count
like that actually means money
i got a million subscribers that means i
make money i don't need views i just
need a subscriber count dude perfect
channel nets at least
14.22 million dollars a year which means
each of the five founding members is
netting the average american salary just
about every week who knows what they'll
be putting that money towards next but
if their past is any indicator we can be
confident they'll keep shooting for the
moon and beyond
dante
bruh this is such terrible breakdown you
just this channel number right they went
to social blade and typed in the
channels and they're making a whole
video about it you could probably make a
fair estimate on someone's income just
like looking at take their merch you can
see how many brand deals they've done
obviously make an estimate and same with
adsense like it shouldn't be that
difficult but they're just like hair
numbers it takes a lot more work okay
than what they're doing here all right
you're asking for a lot
i don't know it's one of the biggest
games on the planet being the most
watched game on youtube in 2019 and
being sold to microsoft for two points
we know that guys
we play with that guys who's getting all
those sweets
is dantdm the uk-based youtuber who set
the guinness world record for most views
on a dedicated minecraft channel with
7.9 billion at the time of the record
which has since been absolutely smashed
currently standing at over 17 billion at
the time of this recording of course
that number climbs every single day and
will likely only increase as minecraft
isn't showing any signs of slowing but
by just how many views is dan breaking
his own world record on the daily while
on average dan's channel gains 6.5
million views every single day which
makes dan not just the biggest minecraft
youtuber but also arguably the richest
making at least seven dan's cpm
has got to be nice
right it's gonna be really good it's
gonna be good thousand dollars a day or
a whopping 6.1 million dollars a year
and that's just from the views on his
come on channel
deals and live shows and dantdm has
mined some serious diamonds
maybe maybe not i don't know
yeah i like dan
yeah
i was kind of worried
whatever dan played games this because
like he's kind of this stuff kind of
family friendly you know i mean
yeah exactly
hey i tried all right i tried my best
did your best yeah i also figured that i
wouldn't want us to go in all pc mode
just because we're playing with him
either right yeah right right right or
maybe not i have no idea he knew what he
was getting into
right he feeling small scale gaming and
subreddit revealing
nonetheless mark fischbach is one i'm
kind of bored of this video i don't know
what
is it because martin just showed up
because they're not actually we can just
go to social blades they're not yeah
exactly they're not saying anything
they're just coming up with numbers and
it yeah with something to get like it's
the clickbait man they got to be able to
put all these people in the description
and everything you know to get views
it's nice shoot seo optimization bro
hundreds of thousands of dollars
channels as big as marks are assumed to
earn for sponsored video markiplier
launched a high-end clothing company
called cloak alongside fellow gaming
youtuber jacksepticeye a brand targeted
at you guessed it gamers with over 51
million subscribers
27 million of which are on markiplier's
channel cloak has definitely got a huge
amount of gamers copying their products
but we're here to see what kind of money
a twenty is cloaked for gamers yeah
i thought it was just like an attempt to
like go for like high fashion or
something because it's there's no rgb
lights on those shirts bro
[Laughter]
it never hit me as a gaming brand
good joke good joke
gotta have those archery beasts let's
watch james the young age of 21 james
charles has accomplished more than most
people could in multiple lifetimes
besides shaking the beauty industry and
preconceptions about what a beauty
influencer can look like to their core
james is creating
is he done
his game's done
hey
yeah
yeah it's
it ain't looking good
it's still uploading it's turning right
yeah yeah still upload still get
millions of views but if you go like
overall viewership you can see hey like
just go to social blade look if you want
to it was definitely taking a hit i
don't know i was super disappointed
emerging subscribers
right
oh my god i do i dare to look at me
what the is this
where are my subscribers
yours is different because it has to
count millions now it can't it can't
count the individual hundred thousands
but you are getting a million every
other month and now it's been three
months bro sorry
bro i was making double views last year
oh rip
well now you're making videos with me
you know it just kind of happens uh
channel you know you stopped being he
gave up on edgy pewdiepie because
you know
how do you feel about that you know i
see it on the reddit people are like
bring back old pewdiepie
how do you feel about it i feel like no
no no i've heard that song since i
started every time they do it it
comes it comes and goes yeah
right well i feel like you've the good
thing about your content is it changes
that you're not doing the gaming anymore
and everyone's like keep doing the
gaming you start doing the more edgy
stuff and now you've felt like you've
got all that out of your system and now
you're on like more like chilling to
react to stuff i mean you're
27 billion views 110 million subscribers
you know you feel like you can just kind
of do what you want to do now oh yeah
what do you think about it um
yeah just doing what i enjoy uh i love i
love the
brackets of these
he's making anywhere between 17 000
to almost 300 000 wow
i must be killing it then because
[Laughter]
well you know mine would just impress
you you would be blown away by mine yeah
my mind's pretty epic yeah
nice anytime i say money doesn't matter
it's like oh yeah rich people talk about
how much it doesn't matter your food no
no all right sorry guess i i was trying
to be helpful all right give it some
hope yeah what do you want me to say
this is the greatest thing ever and
you'll never get rich is that what you
want me to say
yeah stay poor forever being rich is the
only thing that matters is that what you
want me to say
yeah i mean
money definitely does help make you
happy it does like you can buy the
things you need it take you take care of
all your necessities
but if you don't have any goals and
aspirations
before you make money after you make
money that's not going to fill that void
either so you'll still be unhappy and
you will still need to accomplish
something in your life and i think
that's what it really is yeah yeah i
think you're 100 right and i think i
know what i need to fill my void with
yeah what's that um antarctica territory
you see this you see this wine area ken
uh-huh yeah and yeah
do you see this purple area yeah i see
it norway
you see this area
[Music]
yeah i see it do you know what i'm
saying who owns that
i own that
unclaimed it's mine now
i don't care what it takes that's mine
that's mine if enough i thought he was
gonna move to antarctica oh you want to
buy it okay no it's mine i'm not buying
it because it's unclaimed oh you just
claim it i just claimed it it took it oh
my gosh it's mine dude get the articles
ready pewdiepie owns some van or i own
antarctica
if nora can own i can own heck yeah yeah
just wanted to set that right that's
what i'm spending my money on not some
fake
altruism okay
it's
antarctica mine is mine
i'm proud i did it thank you
i feel like you're depressed by this
video are you okay
no i'm just i don't know
no i'm not
definitely not
i'm trying to end it on a nice note and
i don't know how to enter tonight it's
not like money just makes me
uncomfortable at this point i don't know
what to say to be honest i don't know
why i did this video
yeah i mean i can talk about me does
that make you feel better yeah yeah you
go ahead yeah look at that look at this
graph look at this brand
if you believe in yourself
you two can have a second a second
comeback this this
time
holy
the big breakout and now it's it's it's
it's going normal and it's still kind of
going up it's going up a little bit yeah
this is from you know people say that i
ride your coattails this is when i
finally actually jumped on them now
we're making videos together look at
look at it
[Laughter]
yes finally and on that note we will end
this episode what a nice no thank you
for watching if today's your birthday
happy birthday to subscribe so we can
get more money and that's it
i hell yeah you thought it was gay
but true relevance never really died
welcome to the first undead game use any
item in your inventory and make memes
inside tuber simulator add some of our
patented stickers in there stickers our
emotions memes our emotions express your
emotions with me
show them for likes share them for love
get up for free
and who knows
maybe i'll review your memes the
greatest honor of all time full circle
baby download it make a meme
we need subtitles on this